Hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video. Today we're back with our
1hour flipping challenge and what we're
going to be doing today is 1 hour of
flipping freetoplay items. So in actual
freeto play fashion, we are on a freeto
play account. We only have three offer
slots, which is going to be awful, but
you know, it's the the full experience
we're getting here. We're going to be
starting with 20 mil. Uh partly because
some of my money is tied up, but um
mostly because I probably won't need
more than 20 mil with only three offer
slots, limited amount of items. I don't
think that's going to be an issue. And
uh yeah, let's get started. So we have 1
hour on the clock and let's go.
Okay, so what we're going to start with
are something just to get the ball
rolling, which is going to be some
runes.
So, let's see. The nature rune 270
269. Might wait on that one for now.
Law rune buying for 221
and selling for 218. We'll do the law
rune.
And uh the limit on runes is 10,000, but
we're going to do 9,996.
Um,
so I can recheck it later if I have to.
Um, one item I want to be buying for a
while, I think, is mithril ore. It's a
pretty decent item. Always has a pretty
good margin on it.
So, there's going to be a lot of
waiting, I think, cuz we don't have a
lot of slots to work with. Mythal ore
works pretty good.
I don't know if I'm going to do myth.
That's not a very good margin, actually.
Rune twoander
42k
and 41k. I think we'll do the rune
twoander though. Rune two ender will
have a 70 limit on it. There we go. What
about blood runes?
Psych. Not actually free to play.
Actually, I've changed my mind. We're
going to keep one slot available for
that.
Um, what we're going to do is do a bit
of a slower item, but I know I can buy
some of these. And that is going to be
the party hat sets 35550.
And we'll do 40 of these. Okay. So, now
we're pretty much just going to wait for
a little bit. Okay. So, we have bought
the party hatets. Bought four actually
already. And it was only seven minutes.
So, not too bad. But um I kind of think
they are
only have a very small limit. Um sorry.
Let's try 39770.
So that is what I was a little bit
worried about. 39770.
Sure. And the route two rune two handers
have totally bought. No, sorry they
haven't. But pretty close. I'm thinking
about just dumping them in there, but
wait a little bit longer for that. Okay.
Okay, I think we're going to pull the
rune treeers out. It's been a while. Uh,
so we got 59 of them, which is pretty
good. Only 10 more we really could have
gotten realistically. And we're selling
them for
uh
42K, I'm pretty sure.
Um, 41.99.
And yeah, that's a nice 59k profit if we
managed to sell those all. And if you
look here, we have actually sold two
party hats.
Um, so this will be nice. It'll be gone
quickly, but
yeah, not a big limit on this item, so
that's the problem. Oh, we sold another
one. Sweet. Okay, there it is. The last
party hat is sold. So, how much did we
actually make off that? Um, well,
17k. Not too bad, but um it's pretty
good for free to play, actually. It's
just a very slim margin on the item. Um,
that's 814 GP. I mean, it's not too bad.
Since money isn't really an issue here,
we can pretty much buy as much as we
want. Okay, we are back. We just have to
wait a little bit there. And we bought
all the law runes. Um, so let's go
double check that we are selling them
for the same price we bought them for
218 and we're selling for 221. Pretty
decent
actually. Really nice. That's 30k in
profit right there. Okay, so we have
bought all the room play bodies. That is
nice. About 37 minutes remaining
and uh but it has been a while. So,
we'll just recheck the margin. Yeah,
we'll just put it in for that price.
43814.
And yeah, there we go. Rune two handers
again. Very close to finishing. Not
quite done yet. Law runes are about
halfway. Okay, these law runes are
taking a long time to sell. 221. We're
going to take the money out for that and
recheck it because
it's been quite a while. Half of them
did sell, so that's nice. But, uh
Oh, no. It's still the right price.
Okay, that is just taking a while.
Usually this is a lot quicker. So, we're
getting close to halfway done now. We're
so close to selling these rune two
handers. Thinking about just taking out
and dumping the rest. Oh, okay. There we
go. Rune handers have sold finally.
There we go. That was a nice 70k profit
actually. So, pretty decent. Okay, my
ore actually has a 8 GP margin on it
right now. So, we're going to go do that
quickly.
10,000. I feel like the lobsters will
change quickly. Um, so we'll do my ore.
And yeah, we're still just waiting. This
is taking an age. Wow, all my room play
bodies just finished it once. That is
exciting. Okay, we'll take those out.
Let's see if there's the other offer in
there still. No. Yeah. So, we'll do
cooked swordfish.
369 into 374 and 10k swordfish.
Okay, these are working pretty well.
Another large chunk of our myth ore came
through. These law runes are still not
selling. Uh, these really shouldn't take
that long.
[Music]
Let's check it one more time because we
are impatient as
221. I mean, that's it's just taking so
long, but there's Okay, just leave it.
Leave it. And yeah, these swordfish are
actually buying quite quickly. Got 3,000
already. Okay, I think I'm going to pull
the Myithil ore out. It's been a while
since I've bought any. And I mean it's
going to take a little while to sell. So
we bought it for 311.
Throw ore
and we're selling it for 318. Pretty
nice profit.
If we sell this all, we're selling it
for 2344 and we bought it for 2293. So
that's actually 50k in profit, I think.
Uh which is pretty sweet. Swordfish. Um
maybe we'll leave a little bit longer.
Uh cuz they were buying pretty quick,
but we're down to about 20 minutes. 25
minutes left actually. L runes still
have not sold. This is It usually does
not take this long, but whatever.
We will wait, I guess. Okay, I think
we're going to stop buying the
swordfish. We got 4,416 of them. And uh
yeah, let's see what we can actually
sell them for now. It's been a while I
stopped buying.
Hopefully we can actually sell this many
in time.
376 and we bought him four. Okay, not
too bad. And yeah, I'm kind of getting
the feeling this might be our final
stretch. I mean, I just can't imagine
these law runes not selling. It's been
so long. Unfortunately, we're not
getting a chance to do any of the other
runes. Okay, there it is. The law runes
have finally sold. That was the right
price. So, we got another two GP on
those. And yeah, let's see if we can do
another quick flip for runes. Uh, we got
20 minutes left, so I think we can
probably get it done. Let's try death
runes 287
285. Yeah, sure. Death runes
and 99
95. Oh god, we just bought them all
instantly, right away. Okay, well
that'll be interesting.
Death runes
288. Okay.
I What? How does something like that
even happen? Really? All right. Death
runes have dropped down to 285,
which is what we bought them for. H I
don't know. Should we just put them in
for 286? Yeah, 286. Try to get those
sold. We did sell some of them for the
288 mark, which is nice. I guess the
reason we insta bought them is probably
because that was the high price maybe.
Okay, we're down to 11 minutes left. We
pretty much sold all the death runes
back, which is nice. Same with the myth
ore. So, we're just going to
wow. Just wait for these to sell, I
guess. I don't know. Screw it. Uh, okay.
Yeah, let's just dump these. We'll just
lose like 100 GP or something. 600,
whatever. And, um, we'll try to do a
nature rune flip quickly. We don't have
much time, but uh nature runes could go
very quick. At worst, we're not going to
lose very much. Just flip my mouse over.
Hit that confirm button. Okay, we're
down to six minutes left. I don't think
these nature runes are going to buy
anymore. Um so we'll just get rid of all
the stuff we have. Um so I think it went
decently well. If we kept the momentum
rolling to the end, I think we would
have done better, but it's kind of hard
to do that. So yeah, we will sell all
this off. Hopefully all this will sell
in time. I believe it will. And then we
can tally up how much we made.
Oh, we just as I finished that. Okay,
both the natures and the swordfish have
both sold. So that's great. All we got
to do is sell these myithal ores.
Maybe just recheck the margin quickly if
we even can.
Oh, great.
They tanked it a bit, but we don't have
much left, which is kind of nice.
Okay, so we have under a minute left.
We're kind of halfway through selling
the smith ore. Not quite done yet. We're
at 20 mil. Okay. Um, but yeah.
Yeah, I don't know about this. This is
not going to sell.
I'm not really sure how much we probably
made this episode. I'm guessing 100
200k. And before you bash me for that,
go give it a try. Like, it is boring.
It's hard. There's not a lot of items to
do. You only have three offer slots. An
hour in flipping to free to play items
is going to be never going to be that
profitable. But we'll see how much we
actually get. See if it's actually worth
it compared to actual other freeto play
money makers. Um and yeah, there we go.
5 seconds left. We're going to have to
dump these a bit, which is fine. 3 2 1
done.
Okay, let's pull the ore out.
Dump it here quickly.
Okay, so we have 20 mil. Let's see how
much we actually made from one hour of
flipping freeto-play items. We have made
203k.
So, not too bad considering I only have
three offer slots available. Barely not
that bad. You could say I had a 20 mil
start, but honestly, I did not use more
than 5 mil, but I don't think so. You
don't really need that much money. Uh,
and you could actually make 200k an hour
flipping just free play items, which is
pretty decent comparative to other
free-to-play money makers. I mean, at
best you could consistently get maybe
300k an hour, but uh, it's boring as
if you're like trying to buy the
feathers over and over again. That's a
little bit better, but I mean, this you
don't want to shoot yourself, which is
kind of nice. So, yeah, 203k. The best
item probably was the rune two handers.
They flip really quickly. I'd recommend
that for sure. And yeah, that's pretty
much it, guys. Hope you enjoyed and
we'll see you guys in the next video.
[Music]